there's a lot more demand for people who
want to just improve themselves than
anyone would have guessed hi I'm Nick
Gillespie with recent TV and today we're
talking with Salman Khan the founder of
Khan Academy and also the author of the
new book the one world schoolhouse
education reimagined Saul thanks for
joining us thanks for having me
in mid-2012 in the book you mentioned
that Khan Academy had about 6 million
unique visitors to videos online that it
were the kind of early genesis of the
Khan Academy talk a little bit about
what the videos are and then what
surprised you most about the enormous
growth over the past couple of years in
in people watching these videos the
videos and if when people look at it on
Khan Academy org they will see someone
writing just the writing on kind of a
digital blackboard I created with screen
capture the biggest thing is when I made
these things I kind of assumed you could
use for my cousin's there were pretty
motivated students that I kind of make
them for well what would I've wanted
when I was 12 years old or 13 or 18
years old I said well maybe this will be
just for the the subset of people who
are really motivated whatever that means
and and they'll actually seek out
knowledge on the Internet and then
they'll find it useful but it didn't
take long to realize that a lot of the
feedback work anywhere from people who
are not the traditionally motivated kids
who are about to fail classes kids that
were think about dropping out Kipp
people who are going back to school and
they're saying all this the the the
intuition and the connections and kind
of the very conversational nature of
these videos make me comfortable with
math again they make me understand the
intuition the big picture and I'm trying
to get excited about math right so the
big realization is is the and I think
this surprised frankly everybody is
there's a lot more demand for people who
want to just improve themselves than
anyone would have guessed in the book
you mentioned that New York State spends
about eighteen thousand dollars per
student what's wrong with that we're
spending eighteen thousand dollars a
year for flat results over the past 40
years basically from public schools
people millions of people watching your
videos what's wrong with the status quo
the problem is you can never say you're
spending too much in education it's such
an important thing you can never if you
can get a dollar of value in education
it's worth it although that's not what's
been happening every when you look at
the inflation adjusted per pupil
spending
it's been going up and up and recently
and if you do backup you know at first
when you look at the $18,000 number or
in some even the lower the districts
have spent less it might be eight or
nine thousand dollars you multiply that
by how many students are in a classroom
someplace between 20 and 30 you get a
fairly large number you get something in
between three four hundred five hundred
thousand dollars and when you do that
very simple back of the envelope
calculation to realize how little of
that money is actually touching the
student it very little of that is going
to the teacher very little of that is
going directly for the facilities most
of that is going to four layers of
administration and the two things I
point out are 1u we can actually
professionalize treat teachers as the
professionals they are turn it into a
career that pays as well as doctors the
money is there
there's just to be major restructuring
and how you spend that money
the other big thing with that by the way
is there any reason to believe that if
we tripled what we pay teachers we would
have teachers that are three hundred
percent better I don't know I think I
think the the general sense of any
career any profession is you know
there's a lot of lip service being given
to teachers so we need to respect you
either you know we want we want the best
of the best to be doing this but a
society is not sending that economic
signal you know I used to know an
engineering I used to say how come more
people are going into finance and
engineering as well you know look at the
salaries and you get a very clear
picture of why now that tax you're
changing an engineering engineers can
can do just as well or better than
people in finance and I think that has
to happen so that one we are already
getting a lot of great talent in
teaching but we'll get even more people
who aspire to do this and also it'll
change the dynamic in the classroom
where the respect level where the
students say wow I wish I had a chance
of becoming that person who I have the
privilege to be with in this room that
completely changes the dynamic in the
classroom so I think that's possible but
I think the other dimension is it shows
that a lot of the excuses if you will
along you know we can't have
technology's too expensive
those are roundoff error compared to the
amount of money that's being spent even
on things like textbooks and whatever
else and so yeah the back of the
envelope is just really giving people
the big picture you know one of the
things in the book you you really
emphasize is that you know there are
multiple ways of multiple
of Education and I think some of the
stuff that I found most interesting is
just going back and rehearsing we're
modern you know the modern institution
and structures of you know K through 12
education come from the Prussian model
things like that talk a bit about where
the new sites like how we have to really
start reimagining education so it's not
something that happens eight-and-a-half
months a year in a brick building with
you know bad air condition okay yeah and
that's what a lot of people don't
realize we in this education system the
education system actually looks fairly
similar anywhere you go in the world and
so all of us have just assumed this is
what an education is this is what school
is and what I write a lot about in the
book is no this is actually a 200 year
old artefact it comes from the Prussians
who don't they don't exist anymore but
they were kind of the cornerstone of
Germany now is they said we want to have
public education which was a very Galit
aryan idea but how do you do that in a
scalable way in a mass way and they said
well the beginnings of the Industrial
Revolution how do we do anything at
scale and we kind of put things on these
batches in schools it's age-based
cohorts we have a bell ringing every
shift you they go to set pace every
station you try to apply something to it
and at some point you sift the product
this is the good product this is the bad
product that's destined for the you know
the supermarket that that orange is
going to be juiced whatever else and
there's exact same thing with kids and
then when other nations the u.s. being
in the middle 1800s said no we want to
do public education to this of all the
Prussians have gotten a model and we're
going to do the exact same thing that's
how we're going to scale and then in
1892 few people realize you had this
Prussian model already all over the
country but it wasn't standardized in
Massachusetts it would be different than
what's happening in Georgia and so you
had this committee of 10 you know I
write a lot about in the book that
literally sat down headed by the
president of Harvard that decided
physics will be their last year of high
schools chemistry the year before you're
going to do two to three years of
foreign language this is how good
geometry and it hasn't changed since 89
why do you think it is education is one
of the last places that this kind of
personalization and and the revolt of
the kind of Industrial Revolution
mindset the idea of standardized parts
and processes why is it why is it coming
so late to education it seems to be you
know that that's been blown apart in so
many
they're parts of our lives yeah I mean
hopefully the whole sweep of history
won't seem like it's come too late you
know a thousand years from now ago I
just took five years after you know the
travel were here try the I think it's
been a couple you know what almost
everything I write about in the book has
their ideas that have been on a long
time mastery based self-paced learning
there is examples of this being
experimented with in the 1920s and in
the 1970s and they exhale really good
results they were studied and and what
made them very difficult to scale I
think was two things is one everyone
else was indoctrinated in something else
and they just assumed that's what
education was and the other thing is to
actually in 1920 or 1972 do this type of
thing where every student is learning at
their own pace and mastering concepts it
was a huge effort on the part of the
teacher to just coordinate just
coordinate hey you're doing something
different than they're doing how do I
keep track of it they were had to run
around with worksheets and and print out
things and have to grade 30 times more
things that they would have otherwise
had to do and so I think what's happened
now is you've had kind of a confluence
of you have information technology which
has been around for 20 years so you
could say it's late but 20 years isn't
that long the whole sweep of history
that cannot coordinate information and
then that coupled with the idea that
it's the the barrage to consuming of the
information has gone to zero pretty much
zero and the barriers to producing the
information has gone close to zero
before if someone like me wanted to go
out and make lessons for kids in schools
I would have to go pitch some publishing
company then we'd go through some
process pitch it to some top-down
bureaucracy and eventually maybe it
might not have to argue with people
you're teaching it the right way or you
not are you doing and then what gets
down to students will be this weird
watered-down thing now you go straight
to students you can go straight to
teachers you can go straight to parents
and I think all of these things have
come together to kind of create with you
know some of the ideas how you talk
about like flipping the flipping the
school day kind of talked a little bit
about that because these are these are
not even things that would require any
real change other than a change in
attitude yeah I write a lot about this
and we've become somewhat associated
with this notion of flipping a classroom
and one thing I point out it's not my
idea it's not Khan Academy's idea in
2007-2008 teacher started emailing me
say hey you made some reasonable videos
on completing the square or factoring
polynomials I don't think the most
valuable use of my time is a teacher
the teachers time is to give lectures
anymore I can have students do that at
their own time and pace and then in
class we'll make it interactive we'll do
the problem solving so it used to be
homework is now in class what used to be
classwork is or lectures are now are now
at home and there's huge benefits now
and this is the idea that you know the
teachers can help kids work through
problems and explain to the whole class
and then it later in the day when
they're at home or whatever then they
can soak in the lectures at their own
pace that's that's it right and and
we're not you know what advocate is
that's one model which gets closer to
the right idea but then you can keep
running with that you know you don't
have to say it has to happen at home or
it has to happen in school you can do
problem-solving wherever but you should
have some point in the day when humans
do get together where they can help each
other it gives the teacher real-time
information on how are the kids doing
and then it take you to go to the next
level
any time you're lecturing it has to be
one piece if it's all right now if it's
not lecturing it's all the student now
you can everyone learn at their own pace
learn at the stuff that matters and you
can start leveraging peer-to-peer
college and credentials I mean a lot of
education even at the K through 12 level
is kind of signaling to the next level
of Education that you've made the
cautery or the type of person who's
going to go this far
college even more so what's the function
of college and what happens to
credentials down the line when we get
into a more robust and kind of
individualized personalized educational
experience yeah right at length about it
in the book but it's a you know college
is kind of a confusing muddled concept
or even education is where there's a
learning part there's a socialization
part of there's a credentialing part and
you know what I read a lot about is you
know the students and parents yeah they
appreciate the experiential the
socialization parts of college but they
are paying that significant amount if
you really ask them for the credential
you know I joke if you went to students
graduating at Harvard look I'll refund
all your tuition you get all the
experiences you get all the friendships
you get all the learning but you can
never tell anyone that you went to
Harvard University would they do it I
suspect most will not do it in fact most
you have to pay more than the tuition
for them to have to take it back
which tells you that they were paying
for the credential the and the
experience was kind of gravy on top of
that and the universities think that
they're fundamentally not there the cran
shalls' nice but the main thing they're
giving is this experience so that's a
huge
transaction a huge part of someone's
total lifetime income where the person
buying is buying something different
than the person selling and and and what
I believe should happen and what I
believe is happening is you're going to
have a decoupling of the learning
experience
from the credential so regardless of
whether you went to Harvard or you went
to the local community college if you
feel like you know something you could
go to a third party well-established
rigorous assessment better than what
happens in any school and prove that you
know that thing and you might have
learned it on the job at a community
college on Khan Academy on EDX who knows
what it might be and and you do that I
also think it clarifies it for the
university you won't have the strange
thing where kids are trying to make sure
they get an A+ in a philosophy class so
that they can get an interview at
Goldman Sachs or McKinsey or Facebook
they'll be there to learn and if they
really care about the job there's
there's there's another route that's
somewhat orthogonal to the first one
change is coming to the educational
establishment I mean the public school
monopoly the conventional public school
monopoly is clearly breaking down
charter schools are breaking out all
over the place people are opting out of
the system they're you know doing home
schooling or whatever what are the main
impediments to kind of increasing the
pace of change are they and how much of
those reside and they kind of you know
the formal structures of the school of
the educational powers and how much are
in the you know are shackles in the
minds of students and parents I think
they're primarily in the mind I think
they are there is there are structural
things and I've talked to teachers
administrators who believe everything I
say they believe it's the way they look
at other schools that are self-paced
model but they're like no but I got a
state assessment test on this and I got
this calendar that the state has told me
to do and so they have to do this kind
of in-between thing this little dance
where they kind of do lip service to the
state but they recognize that they the
kids have to learn at their own pace so
this is ass weird transition state I've
actually found very few people disagree
with the principal say it's like
actually this is common sense this isn't
like a really even under debate
I actually take the opposite tack
there's there's a lot of cynicism about
change and there's a lot of inertia and
bureaucracy and all of that I actually
think it's happening far faster than
people realize and in five or ten years
it's going to be
completely mainstream and for something
as systemically as important as
education I think that's shockingly fast
the book is the one world schoolhouse
education reimagined the author is
Salman Khan the founder of Khan Academy
thanks for talking to us thanks for
having me for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie
[Music]